[Music]
you performed in Ireland alright and and
you've talked about this because
something went a little awry when you
performed in Ireland which I found
unusual because I would think such a
lovely country what happened well I'm
not Irish which is fine but I'm from
Boston and I hang out my people are
Boston Irish people so I thought I'd you
know I'm kind of like that and so I got
on stage and I'm like Dublin this is in
Dublin at a festival that doesn't really
represent the Dublin people these are
more like the meatheads that come and
are just like beer and like they don't
know what they're seeing right like one
guy one guy walked in with 50 of his
buddies from college and they just
imagine if someone came to this taping
and just brought friends and thought
we'll just talk during it and this will
be our high school reunion like that
like people were using the venue for
that and so I go out onstage and they go
your next comic is an American boo they
were booing going to America meanwhile
there were friends reruns on all day
long in the hotel I'm like oh I guess
you don't like unless it's Rachel Ross
and Chandler you don't like Americans
you know so they booed you even when you
just came up before you said a word yeah
and then I came out and I was like
telling jokes and like Juan divorced and
this very like I assumed Catholic woman
in the front room goes yeah sure that
made it work
but it was like she wasn't people I
couldn't play with her so later the guy
that runs the festival took us all out
for drinks cuz we all needed them a
bunch of the Americans and I was telling
the bartender I was like look at my
Twitter it was like you suck go die
people hated me this is all the people
in Ireland were tweeting mean things
about the people in the audience yeah
howdy Jeff and so he goes oh oh can I
see the word no I can't
[Music]
well the audience has voted in him
that's how this process works I'll say
I'll say the c-word good save yeah I was
out for a drink in the bartender said ah
everyone in Dublin's a bunch of drunk
see words yeah and he said you should
tweet that they'll love it you'll be
right on their level and so I did and
then I got so drunk I forgot I tweeted
it I went to bed woke up the next day
feeling great and I checked my Twitter
and I had death threats and they picked
it up on the news like the TMZ of Dublin
was like comedian comes here and caused
us all a bunch of c-word yeah and a
bunch of my show sold out the next day
people came to see what I had to say I'm
glad they just didn't did they bring
like you know bats it's Dixon they just
brought like bottles of booze but they
didn't want to throw them at me because
they're a bunch of drunken seward's yeah
this problem yeah yeah yeah
so I apologized to them I just sat on
the stage looking really sad and I was
like I made a mistake and you know it
was very Catholic I did confession
that's that's I think you did the right
thing yeah and I stole a doughnut that
night and a cop didn't care so I was
like it's kind of a cool country
[Laughter]
you